documentaire absolument exceptionnel
comment un état de droit peut-il
enfreindre à ce point les conventions
internationales et comment lutter contre
le terrorisme
nous allons revenir longuement sur ces
questions et vous pouvez comme
d'habitude réagir sur le hashtag docu
débats sur twitter avec moi en plateau
pour en débattre marie monique robin
bonjour c'est vous qui avez réalisé ce
documentaire jean pierre chevènement
on ne vous présente plus vous êtes
ancien ministre de la défense ancien
mise de l'intérieur ancien sénateur
merci d'être avec nous pierre connais ça
vous êtes maître de conférences à
sciences po et à l'ena ancien haut
fonctionnaire au ministère de la défense
et vous contribuer régulièrement au
monde diplomatique sur les questions de
terrorisme de géopolitique vous nous en
direz plus tout à l'heure enfin françois
bernard huyghe directeur de recherche à
l'iris vous êtes spécialiste de
terrorisme et de cyber stratégie merci
d'être avec nous
marie-monique robin quelques questions
tout d'abord vous nous montrez ici un
témoignage exceptionnel ce film a déjà
quelques années il y a un rapport à la
cia afin qu'ils qui revient sur cette
torture qui est sorti il y a quelques
semaines on vous connaît pour avoir
réalisé des documentaires sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens sur la
multinationale monsanto
vous diriez aujourd'hui au travers de ce
document que vous êtes dans une démarche
de documentariste engagé
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à faire ce
documentaire alors faites avant de faire
ce documentaire gm avait fait un autre
qui s'appelait escadrons de la mort
l'école française qui était aussi un
livre qui avaient un impact assez
considérable parce que les généraux
argentins que j'avais réussi à
interviewer sont aujourd'hui en prison
enfin s'avérer ouvert enfin contribuer
disons à réouvrir les procès et j'avais
donc déjà travaillé sur la question du
terrorisme et comment commander c'est de
le résoudre et il était sorti très
clairement tous ces entretiens j'avais
plein de généraux pas très recommandable
pour certains aussi bien des français
bigeard aussaresses des américains des
chiliens des argentins que ce qu'on
appelle le terrorisme et est un problème
politique
alors bon temps tortue mobiliser c'est
un petit peu la continuité de ça parce
qu'en fait même l'administration bush
s'est inspirée par ce qu'on appelle
l'école française de la torture oui et
donc de risque et rendement l'école
française je montrais donc comment à
partir de la guerre d'indochine puis de
la guerre d'algérie
on a développé ici à paris les
militaires l'école militaire
j'avais eu accès les archives et surtout
beaucoup de témoignages directs
d'acteurs de cette histoire une nouvelle
théorie de la guerre qui est donc la
guerre antisubversive pour appeler ça
comme ça qui est très très très nouvelle
à l'époque hein parce qu'on n'est plus
dans une guerre comme on a connu pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale avec un front
qui progresse et la danse est pour faire
court 1 et bien la nouvelle guerre c'est
que n'importe qui peut être l'ennemi
peut être un ennemi donc comme n'importe
qui peut être un ennemi 1
eh bien ça veut dire que le
renseignement est une arme absolument
incontournable cette nouvelle doctrine
militaire et donc il dit renseignement
dit torture des disparitions ont disparu
et cette théorie militaire
on appelle ça la french school vraiment
ça atteindre était vraiment enseigné
dans toutes les académies militaires du
monde a fait par exemple qu'il ya un
accord entre le g en français à la fin
des années 1950 avec pierre messmer qui
était à l'époque ministre les armées et
le gouvernement argentin et on a formé
tous les futurs tortionnaires nous les
français chez fin parce que voilà alors
après quand se présente de nouveau c'est
la guerre contre la terreur lancée par
bush et bien effectivement on va
ressortir tous les manuels tous les
savoir-faire français perçoivent la
guerre antisubversive ou le
renseignement est encore une fois larmes
fondamental dans cette conception où
l'ennemi peut être partout évidemment et
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu faire
si torture milieu fait j'avais beaucoup
de contacts dans les milieux la fois
militaires mais aussi toutes les
organisations de droits de l'homme qui
qui travaillent sur ces questions parce
que il ya toujours la même question
moi ce que j'avais compris de cette
première enquête sur l'algérie
l'indochine bon il y avait le front de
libération nationale effectivement les
phalènes on qualifier de terroriste
parce que notamment ils posé des bombes
dans les cafés ag fait très grave on va
pas dire le contraire il ya des victimes
innocentes etc mais quand on veut
traiter une question de terrorisme qui
est un problème politique parler par la
force eh bien d'abord pierre laguerre ce
qu'on a vu en algérie
les américains qui avait été élève de
sarrès par exemple général aussaresses à
fort bragg mais dont on a perdu la garde
et de du vietnam on a fait comme vous
les français et il me disait tous ces
militaires il faut absolument traiter ce
problème politique et le terrorisme de
manière politique et on revoit la même
chose finalement avec torture milieu
les mêmes méthodes et vous voulez faire
un film engagé par par ce biais là
c'était quoi la engagé la torture pour
moi d'un point de vue si c'est ça la
question d'abus de citoyenne
journalistes et citoyenne est très
proche de tout les organismes
humanitaires comme human rights watch
qui m'a beaucoup aidé dans ses pour
faire ce film de retenu des seuils ou
habib sy intérêt pour moi la torture et
d'un point de vue moral absolument un
insupportable et intolérable
mais ce que je trouve aussi intéressant
c'est dans ton et militaires qui vous
disent que d'un point de vue pragmatique
et qu'elle est aussi totalement
inefficace oui donc ça c'est étonnant ce
qui m'intéressait noir c'était comment
la bouche hans quand il a déclaré la
guerre à la terreur septembre vraiment
employer à détricoter toutes les
interdictions d'égal aussi bien les
conventions internationales que les lois
américaines qui font que la torture ou
les mauvais traitements sont absolument
illégaux enfin à droite en ayant recours
à des bataillons de juristes
néoconservateurs qui vont se montrer
habile en fait c'est ce qu'on voit bien
dans votre documentaire jeu justement
jean pierre chevènement est ce qu'on
était au courant de la pratique de la
torture
je crois qu'il faut distinguer deux
périodes il ya la période de la guerre
d'algérie où des officiers qui avaient
perdu la guerre en indochine s'était
juré de ne pas la perdre algérie et
étaient prêts à utiliser tous les moyens
et c'est colonel avait en effet théorisé
une guerre contre insurrectionnelle et
ce sont eux qui étaient derrière le push
qualifié de putsch des généraux du 22
avril 1961 mais il me semble que on ne
peut pas parler comme cela d'une guerre
d'une école française
j'ai oublié du terrorisme comme si
j'étais les institutions françaises qui
mais vous l'avez dit vous-même en 1958
ou 59 ans mieux 7,61 et ça commencera en
58 et c'est une mission officielle de
l'armée française signée par pierre
espère que j'ai interviewé dans mon
documentaire qui l'a reconnu d'ailleurs
je suis que ce film est française a vu
le prix du meilleur documentaire
politique du sénat en plus donc ce que
je voulais dire simplement à faire ces
voix là mais c'est la période de la
guerre d'algérie encore et par
conséquent porte-bébé pas que l'argent
monsieur je vais m'en servir
la tortue se lier au g en français alors
je vous invite lui a tout à fait la loi
et vous vous avez au bout de ma phrase à
l'aise je veux dire qu'il ya une
deuxième période qui est la période qui
suit les attentats du 11 septembre où
les ricains s'avise que après l'invasion
de l'irak notamment qu' il y a eu une
pratique française pendant la guerre
d'algérie dont ils pourraient s'inspirer
et j'ai rentré même le charles pétrie
hausse qui vantait le collège qu'à lui
là on le faisait étudier dans toutes les
académies américaine mais je dis
simplement cela pour qu'on ne considère
pas qu'il ya un continuum je peux vous
dire qu'on a passé la bataille d'alger à
des officiers film le fils à bataille
d'alger qu'on a redonné inquiet
lagardère marie monique valide que ça
fera l'objet entre les gouvernements la
fera l'object d'un autre débat peine
quand même que le général de gaulle a dû
faire face aux complots
deux officier monsieur chevènement si on
revient selon la gendarmerie un
j'entends ça fera effectivement l'objet
d'un autre débat je vous ai envie de
poser mon lit toutefois là si on reprend
la torture post 11 septembre 2001 ce que
ce qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
est ce que la france est ce que l'union
européenne est ce que les autres pays
étaient au courant
vous n'avez pas l'air et le patriot act
a été votée dans le mois qui a suivi les
attentats
ensuite c'est une affaire d'applications
je pense que savait pas grand chose on a
désapprouvé l'invasion de l'irak à chaud
oui mais là on parle de torture
clairement l usage de la torture at il
été la torture il n'a été est vendu
moins quand on lisait les journaux à
l'époque on raconte des choses ça dans
la vie qui se
qui se passait à guantanamo et ont
décrit très tôt en février
donc on a eu un secret de plomb abu
ghraib est connue un peu plus d'un an
par les six ans précision un point sur
un beau ghraib qu'elle avait avant
c'était une prison de saddam hussein où
il ya eu effectivement des tortures à
bamena mais pourquoi tu ont su qu'il y
avait des tortures à banias parce
qu'elles étaient pratiquées par des gens
qui ne cherchaient pas du renseignement
mais qui cherchait c'était un couple qui
cherchait une satisfaction sadique et
qui dans un dans le mouvement sexuel
narcissique à photographier ces
documents et comme il n'était pas très
malin il n'est pas compris le principe
du numérique ces documents se sont
retrouvés à l'extérieur
abu ghraib est un cas particulier mais
en dehors de ça mon ap l'armée
américaine a torturé à utiliser des
méthodes scientifiques
certaines en s'inspirant de la doctrine
galles ou là mais par ailleurs rappelons
qu'il y avait déjà un manuel
d'interrogatoire pendant la guerre du
vietnam en 1963 qui est que vous avez
des méthodes pour faire parler donc peu
importe les plus hauts responsables la
rime avec un y compris le directeur de
cabinet de gameplay je peux vous dire
j'ai tous les documents c'était
déclassifiés ensuite rams feld dit
clairement décrit les techniques qu'il
faut être idiot mais je ne sais pas du
tout à être meilleurs présenté un beau
grec s'était justement comme sacrée et
et on a vu que c'était bad a posé mais
sauf que le film montre et c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est vraiment les très hauts
responsables de l'administration
américaine en ciel qui disent que
c'était vraiment des circulaires qui
étaient là émané de la maison blanche
tout est décrite résidentiel donc c'est
pas et ils ont quand même été condamné
pour des agressions savez je dirais
presque sexuelle mais bon alors monsieur
chevènement et ensuite monsieur qu'au
nettoyage
je pense que la question de la torture
les tranchées historiquement et à tout
point de vue
elle a fait la preuve de son
inefficacité et il faut prendre du champ
et bien voir que ce qui manque dans ces
affaires c'est la vision historique
la vision sociologique la vision des
sociétés auxquelles nous avons à faire
nous utilisons des méthodes qui que ce
soit le renseignement et la torture
s'est d'ailleurs pas la même chose mais
je pense qu'avant cela il faut prendre
conscience du rapport asymétrique qui
existe entre le monde arabo musulman et
l'occident
depuis on peut dire la fin du xviie
siècle qu'est ce que vous entendez par
rapport à symétrique et bien que
l'occident april avantage la dernière
victoire musulmane c'est viennent enfin
c'est même pas une victoire repoussée
sous les murs de vienne en 1683 qu'oscar
empire ottoman va commencer à refluer et
ensuite il y aura le colonialisme c'est
à dire la colonisation de ces pays qui
étaient autrefois des pays sous
l'obédience ottomane donc il se crée un
rapport qui est le rapport
le rapport de force voulait dire bord
colonialisme le colonialisme qui dure
quand même un certain nombre d'années en
algérie 130 en 200 m
et je pense que la torture c'est une
réponse à des stratégies qui utilise en
effet la terreur 1
mais on manque complètement le fond de
la faire si on ne voit pas que par
exemple l'algérie la seule solution
c'était l'indépendance alors là on n'est
quand même pas dans la même thématique
puisqu'il n'est pas question ni
d'indépendance ni de d'une guerre
classique entre entre pays qui
reconnaîtra je me tourne vers vous
est-ce que ça fonctionnait finalement
lent quand on voit ce qui s'est passé à
abou ghraïb quand on voit ce qui s'est
passé à guantanamo qu'est ce qu'on a pu
en tirer de ça moi je me risque à un peu
dans la suite de ce que dit jean pierre
chevènement parce que on mélange des
époques différentes
paradoxalement si vous voulez la
bataille d'alger qui est ensuite resté
comme une tache dans la
la république française a été
tactiquement gagner alors et
stratégiquement la gare était perdu
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement à la
suite des tortures la suite du débat
international et c'est effectivement la
seule issue à ce type de terrorisme et l
indépendance chose qu'on n'a pas voulu
examiner bon donc il ya une partie des
actes terroristes qui ne sont solubles
que par des actes politiques mais on est
aujourd'hui face à une forme de
terrorisme qui n'a pas de solution
politique parce qu'on est face à des
transcendant qui estime que nous sommes
le mal est ce que vous avez le biais
ascendant ça veut dire des gens avec
lequel n'y a pas de champ politique de
discussion puisqu'ils ont leur
instruction directe attendait ils ont
leur instruction directe de dieu et que
par nature si vous voulez la caricature
de mahomet ou de je ne sais quelle
qu'elles violation ou je ne sais quel
comportement de femmes est par nature
condamnable on n'est pas dans un débat
politique
il ya deux ans au fond tous les
terrorismes essais les jours je bouge
qui a introduit cette espèce de mélange
hétérogène en dirait une guerre globale
contre le terrorisme
pourquoi il n'a pas arrêté les irlandais
des basques ou des ou des décors on est
dans quelque chose de complètement
surréaliste il ya un terrorisme qui est
un terrorisme d'origine idéologique
issus du salafisme contre lequel nous
nous battons aujourd'hui est celui là
la tête un corner le champ politique est
fermé il n'y a pas d'interlocuteurs pour
discuter avec donc on efface dans une
situation où militairement on est dans
une dans un type de conflit ou un dans
un type de comment dire de rapport de
force très compliqué j'irai donc on est
on est en face à une situation que qui
est vraiment nouvelle et il ne faut pas
poser problème de la torture uniquement
avec la guerre d'algérie sinon un
tournant surprenant
je me rappelle un monde que cela frise
et il est difficile de négocier avec un
parti dont le secrétaire général
s'appelle dieu donc là effectivement il
ya une différence entre alors on
pourrait discuter pendant des heures sur
la définition du terrorisme sur un
groupe qui a utilise la méthode
politique qui s'appelle tyrosine qui
consiste à utiliser la violence pour
contraindre
un d'état il ya une différence entre un
groupe terroriste qui a des
revendications politiques jean libérez
nos camarades ou libérer le territoire
est une forme de terrorisme je ne sais
pas d'ailleurs pas si le mot terrorisme
est encore suffisant pour décrire ce qui
se passe en ce moment
florac on est vraiment là ils ont amené
un état un état
qui torturent bien davantage mais le là
nous sommes en face de gens qui veulent
nous punir lorsque les frères kwasi et
on y reviendra
il n'a pas souvent on va y revenir très
largement marie monique robin
moi je continue de dire enfin me font
sur ce qu on dit par exemple arrivent
ils cassent leur site le colonel qui
était le directeur de cabinet de karim
fall qui s'était d'ailleurs opposé à
l'intervention en irak
il fallait parce qu'un think tank de
militaires qui ne vous qui étaient
contre l'intervention américaine en irak
et qui ensuite quand moi je le rencontre
en 2008 est absolument désespérez pas ce
qui s'est passé il dit le problème du
terrorisme c'est qu'il ya un terreau
pour recruter des apprentis terroristes
et ce terreau le c'est un terreau
politique et lui me dit qu'il arrive
c'est quoi le il me rappelle que
d'ailleurs ben laden au moment des
attentats de 2001
eh bien c'était rien du tout c'était il
y avait pas de soutien populaire c'était
des gt très peu nombreux et que huit ans
après et bien c'est des légions
d'apprentis terroristes et des
terroristes enfin qui prend les armes
véritablement il dit le problème
politique c'est alors il a plusieurs
strates
évidemment c'est la question
palestinienne non résolus près c'est la
misère des pays de ces pays là c'est le
fait qu'on veuille piqué le pétrole
c'est là aussi comme on les perd
connaissance à celle des droits
politiques qui va faire que bien des
jeunes et les frères kwasi moi je suis
j'ai écrit là-dessus sur mon blog en
france on prolonge et que c'est le
racisme qui datent de bologna l'isthme
des raisons française on a du mal à du
93 moi par exemple dont dans ses
banlieues
marie-monique robin on aura largement le
temps avant de passer
je voudrais qu'on revienne tout de suite
après sur ce que disait donald rumsfeld
dans votre documentaire dernière
question on a vu que ni george bush ni
d'un alros faits n'ont pour l'instant
été inquiété après ces rapports pour
quelle raison parce que ce système les
auditions américaine très intéressant
parce que moi j'ai plongé dans senteurs
d'archivés de 6 panne de la chaîne
parlementaire ils ont donc après le
scandale d'abou ghraib ou il ya des
photos qui sont publiées dont ils sont
obligés de réagir quelque chose
reinfeldt à mentir sous serment serment
j'étais pas au courant et où le film
montre qu'il était au courant il savait
pertinemment que ces documents sont là
mais là le est donc grave à d autres de
lever l'immunité à la tradition c'est
magnifique parce que tout le monde
toutes et tous des ballons quasiment
dans nos fans c'est formidable c'est
archi sort bien mais c'est pas ils vont
jamais de poursuivre ils d'accord et
bâle et puis on ne fait débat n'est que
des seconds couteaux à 100 est quand
même venu témoigner
finalement bien mais en gros georges
bush colin powell exceptionnel que rien
n'est pas le congrès américain toujours
refusé de lever l'immunité ou ferment ou
même faire ce qu'ils ont voulu faire
pour clinton dans la ferme dans la
sphère de monica et pour des raisons qui
sont expliquées dans le film aussi
placer ses protagonistes c'est qu'aussi
tout le monde a été dans l'union
nationale et il ya eu une période
d'après le 11 septembre c'était très
difficile de deux critères tout le monde
a les démocrates y compris un suivi
bouche
voilà bah transition toute trouvée
monsieur sur l'iran je vous donnerai la
parole si vous voulez bien après je
voudrais justement qu'on réécoute d'un
aileron c'est parce que pour préparer
l'opinion justement à s'affranchir des
conventions de genève
c'est le secrétaire à la défense qui s'y
est collé on écoute
alors ami jean pierre chevènement quand
on entend le donne un drôle ça deale que
dire qu'effectivement c'est pas une arme
et qu'il n'y a pas de ligne de front que
après tout il a un petit peu raison est
ce qu'on peut encore appliqué des
conventions comme celle de genève à des
gens qui ne sont pas une armée régulière
il y à un grand danger à s'affranchir du
droit et l'expérience du patriot act le
montre ce révélé globalement inefficace
à la brb a montré beaucoup de choses
il ya aussi un livre qui a paru c'est un
mauritanien mohamed ould slahi si ma
mémoire est bonne qui a été cuisiné
d'abord à il était en mauritanie a été
enlevés transportés en irak puis de là
fini à guantanamo et c'est à partir du
moment où la torture est qu'il a
commencé à dire des choses qui n'avaient
rien à voir avec la réalité et par
conséquent c'est très dangereux en plus
ça sape la confiance que les démocraties
doivent avoir en elle même et il faut
toujours remonter loin en arrière dans
nos rapports avec le monde arabo
musulman
nous avons je dirais c'est d'aider des
gens qui ont appartenu à des
civilisations extrêmement brillante qui
ont atteint le comble du raffinement à
l'époque des omeyyades des abbassides et
beaucoup d'autres mais naturellement
nous constatons depuis deux siècles un
déclin auxquels ces populations ont
répondu oui enfin leur intelligency a
répondu de manière une variante
modernisatrice à l'école de l'occident
libéralisme ou socialisme laïque et puis
une variante identitaire retour aux
sources
bon ça peut prendre une forme qui est
celle des frères musulmans
ça peut prendre d'autres formes mais
nous mêmes nous ne sommes quand même pas
tout à fait étranger à cette affaire
nous voyons que des shows développe à
partir de l'irak
mais rappelez-vous en 1991
l'intervention à mon avis totalement
évitable de la coalition regroupée
autour des états unis eau
après l'invasion du koweït personne ne
sait que saddam hussein avait proposé
d'évacuer le koweit à 1 et de l'évacuer
à condition qu'on remplace ses soldats
par des troupes arabes simplement les
américains avaient déjà installé cinq
cent mille hommes au moyen-orient était
guère question qu'il ne fasse pas la
guerre il avait décidé dès le premier
jour c'était leur but ils voulaient
avoir je dirais des trous au
moyen-orient il voulait plus passer par
un gendarme régional
donc il y a eu cette première guerre
suivie d'un long blocus qui a entraîné
beaucoup de souffrance et de mort puis
une deuxième guerre qui était la guerre
d'invasion à laquelle la brb a fait
allusion qui a détruit un demi à arradon
en 2003 qu'il détruit l'état irakien ont
le dise où la police armée
la fonction publique et je pense que
nous nous récoltons aujourd'hui les
fruits de cette totale désagrégation de
l'état irakien
les sunnites qui avaient dominé et
l'irak pendant longtemps sont
aujourd'hui évidemment relégué très loin
vous guéret le pouvoir il ya trois
grandes composantes
on va revenir effectivement sur cette
question peut pas comprendre ce
phénomène de dèche
si on fait l'écho 2008 mais une petite
revanche sur ce que va devenir notre
entraînement c'est dos que vous
d'autant plus vrai puisque c'est au
moment de la première guerre du golfe en
mettant des soldats sur la terre sacrée
de l'arabie saoudite qu'on a déclenché
j'allais dire fait péter les plombs à
ben laden en tout cas nous lui avons
infligées l'auf en symbolique dont a
résulté tout le reste échoue à la chine
et qui était à l'époque ministre de la
défense qui était venu me voir pour me
dire qu'est ce que vous pensez tout ça
on dit que vous n'êtes pas tout à fait
d'accord et je suis dit en effet que si
vous devez briser les chine de la seule
de selecta laïque c'est une dictature
mais c'est un état laïque au
proche-orient qu'est ce que vous allez
faire vous allez avantages et
l'intégrisme un sous ses formes diverses
chiites et sunnites et d'autre part vous
allez donner la domination de l'argent à
l'iran m'écouter il a même pris des
notes parce qu'elle est très gentil puis
les notes m'a dit oui c'est très
intéressant
il a tenu pas le moindre compte comme
saint-pierre connaît ça je voudrais
quand même aussi aller en complément de
ce que va dire jean pierre chevènement
sur le la méthode de la façon de mener
une guerre
la première phase de la guerre d'irak à
celle dans laquelle on est
malheureusement toujours a été une
victoire conventionnelle ce n'est la
suprématie américaine fait que
l'utilisation des moyens technologiques
avancés permettent de détruire toutes
les infrastructures de l'adversaire et
de réduire son état zéro donc c'est une
guerre au sens classique du terme était
une guerre aux bouches se dit bon pousse
maintenant on arrête ces fiches manière
le problème c'est que les iraniens les
irakiens qui n'avait plus ni l'eau ni
l'électricité ni la police ni l'armée ni
la sécurité des avec des armes circuler
par tous devaient être contents parce
qu'il avait la démocratie voyez le
paradoxe de la date de la contradiction
entre le moyens militaires et l'objectif
politique suivie d'autre part j'ai
beaucoup aimé le film
mais cela dit moi je trouve qu'il ya
quelque chose de fascinant dans le
système américain c'est que c'est un
système autonettoyant à la fin on va
demander à clinton de faire des excuses
publiques parce qu'il a menti au sénat
parce qu'il s'est fait faire une
fellation par des stagiaires mais george
bush continue à jouer au golf tous les
week-ends et on ne lui demande rien
d'autre part là où on s'est trompés nous
je dirais la jean pierre chevènement
mieux placé que moi c'est qu'on n'a pas
vu monter cette espèce de conservatisme
à l'américaine qui était le
conservatisme impérialistes c'est à dire
que la guerre était planifié depuis
longtemps
il réalise
annie fier depuis quand le texte étaient
effectivement 93 10 explique les moyens
pour que les etats unis gardent la
suprématie du monde et on a ce tour de
passe-passe stratégique extraordinaire
où il ya 15 saoudiens sur 19 terroristes
en septembre et en janvier 2002 bush
explique au monde entier que l'ennemi
c'est l'iran l'irak et le corée du nord
et tout le monde avait du mal dont
claque du mal oui mais je n'ai rien sur
l'arabie saoudite
donc cette espèce de tour de passe-passe
stratégique est extraordinaire nous nous
sommes laissés complètement enfumé
contre toi ça bien sûr on s'est laissé
enfumer pour se laisser enfumer
là aussi entre avec la presse qui s'est
laissé enfumer longtemps en tout cas
dans sa souvient de collines powell au
siège de l'onu oui mais avec sa fiole
lorsque les jusqu'à mais il a dit qu'il
y avait rien de dangereux dire si je
vois que je pourrais très ému personne
la reprise allait départager à cette
époque là parce que jacques chirac avait
pris une position peu nettes et
courageuse donc la presse a été partagée
mais moi j'ai le souvenir de la
précédente guerre du golfe qui avait été
décidé le 3 août au matin ou le 2 août
dans la nuit par monsieur bush père et
madame thatcher un l'enfumage était
mondiale sont allés je peux vous dire
vous savez là on vient ma vie que de
travailler dans des bébés dans extraits
par les soldats irakiens d'une couveuse
dire montage total y avait aucun rapport
claret le monde pour faire canadien sur
le sujet c'était la fille de
l'ambassadeur à washington
il jouait l'infirmier enfin c'était un
bidonnage complet bidoli très peu
d'image et le formatage opinion est
quelque chose qui me terrifie
rétrospectivement car la vérité ne se
fait jour que très longtemps après si
encore elle se fait jour si je vous dis
que cette guerre a été déclarée dans la
nuit du 2 au 3 septembre
c'est que je peux vous donner des
arguments tout à fait vérifiable ou
lisez une petite brochure publiée par
l'institut françois mitterrand roland
dumas raconte
sa vie avec françois mitterrand et vous
donne trois ou quatre pages tout à fait
explicite quand françois mitterrand lui
dit et ce que nous sommes avec les
américains dans cette guerre quelle
guerre midi mais la guerre qu'ils vont
faire un j'ai eu un coup de téléphone
séduits ils vont faire cette guerre
alors où sommes-nous de quel côté nous
sommes en dehors ou bien nous sommes à
côté est bon et ben alors justement je
voudrais qu'on réécoute puisque on
entend george bush dans le documentaire
de marie monique robin en 2003 qui nous
parle de l'irak qu'il souhaite
on l'écouterait repousse donc l'irak un
pays sans agression du voisin sans
violent sans rien en gros on se chambre
100 chambres de torture
on se rend bien compte que quasi quinze
ans après la la le début de cette guerre
c'est un chaos absolument absolue l'irak
sont aujourd'hui des shs dit l'état
islamique qui n'est pas en état
jean pierre chevènement quand vous voyez
le résultat aujourd'hui qu'est ce que on
a raté quand je parle de on sait on les
a si on la vengeance union européenne et
du viol caractérisé la souveraineté du
comedd qui avait commis saddam hussein
après une guerre avec l'iran ou l'avait
encouragé poussée des rames enfin voilà
tout ce qui aurait pu être traitée avec
des moyens proportionnés sans violence
inutile
moi je ne suis pas pacifiste je tiens à
le préciser je n'aurais pas été ministre
de la défense autrement mais je suis
pacifique
je pense que un problème qu'on peut
résoudre par la diplomatie c'est
préférable que de le résoudre par une
violence
et par la guerre car la guerre ouvre
toujours une boîte de pandore on
n'arrive pas à la preuve appel à
d'autres exemples en europe même je
pense à 1914
ouais mais ce qui s'est passé au
moyen-orient à ce moment-là a ouvert un
cycle de guerre dont on n'est pas sorti
alors on voit maintenant la guerre
sunnite dechy de l'iran allié à la syrie
et au hezbollah
donc je pense que nous nous récoltons
évidemment le terrorisme sur le
territoire national il faut lutter
contre mais je pense que là le la loi
qui vient d'être adoptée par le
parlement et celle qui est en
préparation
je les ai lues avec attention ne
comporte pas d'atteinte aux libertés
fondamentales
il y a évidemment des pouvoirs qui sont
données sur internet sur les sites
internet mais ça me paraît quand même
normal que l'opérateur ait une certaine
responsabilité
et puis il ya une nouvelle incrimination
qui est la criminal sion de préparation
d'un attentat terroriste alors là il
faut vérifier que on est en conformité
avec un principe constitutionnel qui est
celui de la légalité des délits et des
peines
oui mais je dirais que c'est très sûr à
ce projet de loi crée du droit ouais on
a les moyens de lutter ils ont france
nous avons je le rappelle une
législation antiterroriste qui
centralise les enquêtes et poursuites
dans les mains de la police
anti-terroriste des juges pouvons
antiterroriste cid ailleurs ayant
autorité sur celle là qui reconnaissent
à venir si vous voulez à ce que l'on
pourrait donner comme définition du
terrorisme
si on ne prend qu en termes de violence
un acte terroriste est un acte dont
l'effet médiatique est supérieur à
l'effet stratégique
c'est ça la définition la plus claire
qu'on puisse avoir ce qui fait un fait
divers finalement c'est à dire que on
lui a constaté avec l'égorgement des
quatre jours on a des quatre occidentaux
par des ch
ça a provoqué l'émoi de l'opinion
publique et a obligé le politique ou en
tout cas il s'est cru obligé de faire
une intervention militaire donc on est
retombé dans le même piège que celui qui
était le début de la guerre d'algérie
rappelez-vous l'exécution des époux
monroe qui 3 2
instituteur un couple d'instituteurs qui
partait prendre leur pause dans les
aurès le bus s'est arrêté
ils sont tués sont abattues le la classe
politique qui se lancent en exclamations
sur le thème ça ne se passera pas comme
ça les assassins seront poursuivis vous
connaissez la fin de l'histoire
bon donc c'est pas l'acte terroriste en
lui-même qu'il faut prendre c'est
effectivement le champ politique dans
lequel cet acte s'inscrit et si
effectivement on continue à aller
aujourd'hui en irak
on est accompagné d america c'est quand
même le quatrième présidents américains
successifs qui décident d'une
intervention militaire en irak
le quatrième alors vous êtes irakien
quel que soit votre orientation
politique autre orientation religieuse
vous pouvez commencer à en avoir un peu
assez que le votre sécurité se situe se
joue là bas washington et donc on
continue dans ce champ où l'action armée
tient lieu d'analysé politique et
sachant cela pour revenir sur votre
définition de terrorisme on n'est pas
dans une guerre classique à qui on a
affaire
le terrorisme on a toujours hésité sur
sa définition pour savoir si c'était la
guerre du pauvre c'est l'expression qui
a été souvent employé ou la propagande
par le fait à dire tuer quelqu'un pour
démontrer que l'état et répressif qui a
des crampes aux yeux je crois que c'est
les deux à la fois
et effectivement le but du terrorisme
c'est pas de faire un gros tas de mort
c'est premièrement de faire beaucoup
d'heures de télévision et de provoquer
des réactions de l'adversaire qui vont
également c'est une provocation aux
sciences étymologique du terme on
cherche à provoquer une réaction adverse
mais c'est pas nouveau parce que si on
reprend les guérillas fin vous parler de
la guerre d'algérie est ce que le fln
était pas dans des actes de terrorisme
tout à fait action directe les brigades
rouges etc c'en était déjà on a
l'impression peut être un peu de re
découvrir à chaque fois des choses qu'on
connaît depuis déjà longtemps suspendant
que je nuance le but du fln c'était l'un
des points là le but des chaussées le
califat islamique mondiale s'est dressé
le monde musulman tout entier contre
l'occident même pas seulement contre
l'occident parce qu'ils se mettront à
dos la russie la chine l'inde et cetera
donc c'est le monde musulman contre le
monde entier c'est un roger fou et
naturellement il faut le combattre avec
sang froid à la drogue sérénité
marie-monique robin comment un combat
alors moi je
l'amarante de la fin de la partie
précédente je voulais vous transperce
comme on dis ces acteurs voyez bon voilà
que de haut niveau que j'ai rêvé j'ai
réussi à trouver
alors moi je vois dans en france comment
on fait c'est plutôt la citoyenne qui a
rencontré tous ses acteurs mais moi je
parle en tant que citoyenne cette fois
ci j'ai beaucoup observé le parcours des
frères kwasi bon j'en ai dit moi
j'habite dans 93 elle se voit on voit à
saint denis pour vous dire où j'habite
ben que l'islamisation radical dans la
population se voit
oui vous allez au marché comme moi
samedi je vois d'accord
moi j'ai écrit deux sur mon blog j'avais
un petit peu peur de me faire allumer
mais je l'écris quand même j'ai beaucoup
de soutien finalement que pour moi les
affreuses tuerie de mémoire un à la fois
de charlie et puis évidemment de
magasins casher n'étaient pas des faits
de guerre mais d'atroces faits divers
voilà j'assume ça je veux dire par là
que pour moi les frères krouchi c'est
des pauvres mecs de banlieue qui ont
absolument
enfin comme beaucoup de ce que je vois
vivre autour de moi dans les cités au
tour qu'il n'aura absolument droit à
rien je suis assez d'accord avec manuel
valls quand il a prononcé le mot
d'apartheid parce que je le vois à
l'heure à l'oeuvre dans les cités autour
de moi j'habite pas aurait cité mais
jamais tout à côté et je pense que ils
sont
il ya un désespoir terrible dans tous
ses sites et il n'y a pas de travail à
du racisme qui journal a parlé avant qui
est évident et en gros mois qu'un
produit c'est moins séduit la ville
c'est celle dans laquelle arrive au
lutin fabrique aussi introduit du du
racisme du manque de multiculturalisme
alors la faiblesse reproché à françois
zimeray j'ai des doutes je finis après
je voulais vous dire moi je suis très
troublé par le fait que par exemple
koweit
on a laissé investir dans les banlieues
50 millions d'euros ce qatar également
pardon vous casser la tronche je me
trompe le qatar le qatar le qatar bon
maintenant c'est 100 millions de l'état
français mais 50 me et et ça c'est une
incohérence absolument incroyable parce
que comme ça a été dit a plus vraiment
dur en amical c'est vraiment un islam
qui est ce que prône se libéra
très honorable et finance et on les voit
dans le 93 ces associations et je ne
comprends pas la position du bolmon
français actuel d'avoir repris cette
proposition d'ailleurs de sarkozy du
monde avant et on est dans l'incohérence
sa plus totale parce que effectivement
sur un terreau de désespoir de crise
économique très un convoi très
clairement dans ces sites est vraiment
très clairement et bien c'est vraiment
mettre du poison et du poison et voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est mais gravement
que les frères couach ils vont devenir
des monstres et ben justement françois
bernard huyghe
comment est ce que vous expliquez que
des trajectoires comme celle des frères
kwasi et puis à un moment croisé celle
de l'état islamique dèche
alors ça c'est le mystère des âmes et de
l'api gagner mais on a on me semble un
nouveau type avec meyrannais gauche les
frères kouachi le média ibérique polybe
à l'issue d'anjou biel non canada celui
d'anna castéra on voit des gens qui ont
des duran jeudi rizon ils ont des
testostérones est de la veine aline ils
n'ont pas forcément été dans une misère
atroce où ont parfois eu des aides de
l'état et propre providence ils ont fait
un passage par la case de l'entente sont
pas forcément radicaliser en prison mais
souvent et puis il ya un moment où ce
ressenti alors jurica de les élancées du
ressentiment c'est à dire ils
s'assimilent absolument tous les les
musulmans martyrisé à travers le monde
et il met dans le même sac que les morts
d'irak les medal estime ya les syriens
ou le gars un peu bronzé qui a eu un
regard
deux travers du cafetier raciste il met
tout dans le médecin même sac pour en
faire une pulpe habilité quasi
métaphysique général et ils adhèrent à
à cordis idéologique très très simple il
leur suffit dans sa simplicité
il ya le licite et l'illicite tu dois
tuer des gens qui ont dû caricaturé le
prophète tu gagneras le paradis c'est
dans une logique du talion l'expression
de ben laden lui-même
vous avez versé du sang des femmes
palestiniennes etc
nous vous ferons verser autant de sens
pierre conesa moi je voudrais un peu
m'inscrire un peu en décalage par
rapport à ce qui se dit en ce moment sur
l'apartheid
ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé quand j'ai
fait l'étude sur la contreuse quelle
politique de contrôle radicalisation en
france c'est que paradoxalement l'islam
de france a trouvé sa place
c'est un peu paradoxal de le dire comme
ça mais si vous voulez il ya une classe
moyenne qui aujourd'hui c'est intégrer
on ne demandant pas la différence mais
la différence il demandé simplement
qu'on leur demande pas s'ils étaient
musulmans à tout bout de champ dont ces
gens là ont fourni leur ebit artistiques
culturels littéraires l'industriel etc
vous avez des success-stories altrad le
leader de l'udps une l'échafaudage de
bâtiments est un enfant des deux turcs
et deuxième caractéristique que je
trouve très intéressante
il m'est arrivé dans certaines banlieues
de voir des représentants de la
communauté turque qui ne sont pas par
rapport à la france dans le discours de
la victimisation et du post coloniale et
dans la communauté turque vous avez une
espèce de culture entrepreneuriale qui
fait que les gens se regroupent à
l'arrière france responsables de leur
malheur ils viennent ici dans la
psychologie des italiens des polonais 10
à 30 ans bon donc arrêtons sur le thème
c'est effectivement la ghettoïsation
nous sommes victimes de tous et ce
décalage du discours est extraordinaire
rapport à la réalité
aujourd'hui vous avez une mobilisation
des classes moyennes musulmans contre la
radicalisation c'est à dire de gens qui
justement considère que cette
radicalisation tue plus de musulmans que
de non musulmans statistiques mondiales
et que aujourd'hui la place de ces
musulmans dans la france c'est de lutter
contre la radicalisation
donc on est dans un champ politique
totalement nouveau si la classe
politique mais pas quand même d'entendre
ça et de tenir un autre discours que
celui de la victimisation culpabilisante
on ne sortira pas de ça voilà vous
disiez aussi quelque chose avant qu'on
démarre cette émission que je trouvais
assez intéressant c'est que pour revenir
sur la question du corpus idéologique
aujourd'hui on efface en fait à des
enfants qui cherchent à tout prix
à adhérer à quelque chose sauf que sur
le marché de l'idéologie il n'y aurait
plus que l'islam radical
c'est à dire qui est un processus qui
est celui des recrutements sectaire
qu'on a connu dans d'autres domaines un
qu'on a connu avec jim johnson aux états
unis qu'on a connu c'est celle idéologie
sectaire c'est à dire la fin du monde
est pour bientôt d'ailleurs regardez
tous les signes sont là fukushima le
réchauffement de la planète étaient là
mais ce qui fait le facteur de
mobilisation de la radicalisation
salafistes c'est la guerre en syrie
parce qu elle se raccroche à une phrase
qu'avait dit le pré fall au fait sur le
fait que c'est là que la bataille de
l'armageddon les finales du bien se
passerait et donc ce thème de la
mobilisation est très fort et le
deuxième aspect de recrutement sectaire
c'est celui qu'ont constaté ailleurs
c'est-à-dire tout à coup l'individu
isolé entre dans une communauté d'élus
qui va tout à coup lui offrir une
idéologie totalitaire dans lequel on
aura explications de tous c'est à dire
que ça va très loin dans le détail ce
que faisait le lien assez dense illicite
est donc tout à coup ces individus
deviennent quelqu'un alors pourquoi je
m'inscris en faux dans le discours de la
victimisation économico sociale c'est
qu'on a le phénomène des convertis
aujourd'hui ne sont pas au tube
négativement des gens issus de ces
banlieues
donc on a un phénomène idéologique il
faut essayer de démonter celui là on le
connaît mal il faut essayer de le
comprendre et surtout pour construire
une contre-discours il faut connaître le
discours alors rapidement parce qu'on a
plus beaucoup de temps jean pierre
chevènement est ce que pour lutter
contre ces formes ces nouvelles formes
de guerre asymétrique guérilla on sait
même pas vraiment comment les déterminer
est-ce qu'il faut intervenir sur le
terrain en syrie en irak ce que il faut
d'abord s'appuyer sur les peuples
musulmans qui doivent eux mêmes se
débarrasser de ce venin terroristes et à
l'ancienne les moyens alors on peut les
aider enfin il y a manière et manière de
les aider mais je crois que c'est
d'abord leur responsabilité comme c'est
aussi la responsabilité des élites
musulmanes maghrébine ou issus de
l'immigration de faire aussi que chacun
puisse comprendre que naturellement ces
fois là ne représente en aucune manière
l'islam qui est une
religion qui portent d'autres messages
que le message de la haine
je crois que ça c'est un travail que
seuls peuvent faire les musulmans je
vais lancer le jeu des 1000 intérieur la
consultation qui a donné lieu ensuite à
différentes réunions de commissions plus
permis de régler le problème des
mosquées le premier de des imams n'est
pas anti pas encore calmée mais je ne
crois pas non plus la culture de
l'excusé sociologique
l'un des frères cauchy et coulibaly il
avait des diplômes un bep de il y avait
un salaire de 2200 euros par mois
je pense beaucoup plus qu' il y a
vraiment un problème idéologique et un
problème de ressentiment est lui une
haine et qui s'alimentent à diverses
sources
et pour y répondre il faut aussi donner
chez nous le l'image de la justice plus
l'image de la justice et l'image de la
république et des valeurs de la
république qui doivent être expliqués
elles ne sont plus compris aujourd'hui
alors ils doivent être expliquées
justement et notamment par l'école une
minute rapidement sur les solutions
juste une remarque pourquoi il faut être
extrêmement prudent dans la démarche
politique politiques et policières et
judiciaires rappelez-vous dans la
famille mais rares y avait trois frères
oui il y en a un qui est devenu sur
l'assassin qu'on connaît il y en a un
autre qui est un salafiste qui se
prétend quiétiste mais qui a beaucoup
aidé son frère il ya celui qui les a
dénoncé un livre on avait le même
scénario dans la famille moussaoui qui
était celui qui part était à londres et
qui voulait faire un un attentat dans un
avion vers les états unis
donc il faut être extrêmement précis
dans la qualification est dans la façon
dont on va mener la vie à l'art
policiers ma conclusion marie monique
robin sur les solutions mois moi je leur
ai dit que j insiste on n'est pas
d'accord là dessus je suis très inquiète
parce que je vois moi autour d'eux
vie et je pense que véritablement il ya
un processus de ghettoïsation
extrêmement avancé dans les arrivées par
les salafistes dans les banlieues est
vraiment de problème c'est économiques
sociaux énormes et qui sont à mon avis
très inquiétant jeu et donc si on veut
couper l'herbe sous le pied à ceux qui
recrutent
il faut arrêter de couper les
subventions aux organisations laïques
qui font un énorme travail maisons qui
n'ont plus un sou parce qu'en ce moment
où partout il faut pas couper vrai
plutôt couper le robinet au qatar ça oui
voila je pense que vraiment ouais il ya
la démence au mois trois importants dans
la capacité évidemment d'avoir un
terreau encore une fois ci fait s'il
faut attendre d'être dans une société
juste et prospère pour que ça
disparaisse le ciel vous entende
j'ai un tout petit sur cette solution
alors historiquement on voit qu est ce
qui a marché contre le terrorisme
comment est-ce que des groupes
terroristes ont disparu sur parce qu'ils
sont convertis en parti politique
classique soit parfois parce qu'ils ont
gagné ça ça arrive aussi
soit parce que on les a écrasés par des
méthodes policières lente alors il faut
du renseignement il faut taper sur les
bons et uniquement sur les bons mais par
exemple quand on a des cas comme kouachi
coulibaly et ses super signalait etc
il ya un problème aussi de faire du
positivisme juridique duo maintenant
rester un peu en prison et si les
dossiers devant seulement était suivi ça
serait peut-être pas plus mal
monsieur celle ci je peux dire encore un
mot nous avons connu des phénomènes de
terrorisme les années 60 70
la bande à baader a bien sûr rect les
brigades rouges
mais il n'y avait pas de terreau
ouï-dire la classe alors aujourd'hui ne
se sentait pas à l'aise sur un
présenterait là il y à un terreau et
c'est pour ça que il faut que la
république s'affirme dans tous les
domaines y compris en matière économique
en matière sociale c'est nécessaire pour
que le
on comprenne qu'il ya quelque chose
d'autre à l'horizon que c'est de ces
ténèbres bon les bases du terrorisme
merci beaucoup monsieur cholet avant ce
sera le mot de la fin je suis désolé
merci à vous d'avoir été parmi nous pour
ce débat on espère vous avoir éclairé la
semaine prochaine vous retrouverez
laurent bazin pour un docu débat sur
l'avortement à tout autre programme en
attendant vous pouvez réagir sur notre
adresse mail à bientôt
enfin